[Music]
remember when you and your friends used
to have crushes on guys you knew you'd
never meet
great big story remembers
this is clayton snyder he played ethan
craft
lizzie mcguire's crush on the disney
channel show lizzie mcguire
he was the lovable jock athlete at
school that
people wanted to be or be with hey
what's up guys hey
let's be clear lizzy had a huge crush
on ethan do you see ethan a sentiment
echoed by many others
let's break down his luck cargo shorts
were a must
he needed pockets for all the scrunchies
that were gonna get thrown at him
throughout the day
and puka shells or some sort of
necklace ethan's character was cute but
not necessarily the brightest crayon
in the box
ethan was known for a few things one of
them
would be how he couldn't do long
division how many times do we have to go
over this
and the other is that he has the hair
the hair is a big part of who
ethan was and he knew it as well
ethan was originally written as the
bully but once everyone came to set
the production rewrote his character
playing ethan
was so much fun there was
one episode of that was this school
dance night
where the action line just said ethan
dances like a madman
and i went with it and they had to tell
them to calm down because my feet were
making too much noise
on the set as far as crushes go lizzy
and ethan never got past friendship
ethan didn't kiss a soul on liz mcguire
not in the show not in the movie
i think that says something about ethan
i think he was a class act
since the show ended clinton's done a
few gigs played some water polo
sold some houses but most importantly
he's been working on the lizzie mcguire
reboot
the pretty boy robert richard's roles
tended to have
one thing in common a lot of my roles
became
rob rochelle with this shirt off
[Applause]
[Music]
but before he became known as the pretty
boy he had humble beginnings playing the
sweet and smart bobby in cousin skater
the producers of the show wanted to make
him a relatable 90s kid
my outfits were a lot of levi's jeans
reebok sneakers the traditional 1990s
polo or a t-shirt and a jacket that was
sort of like the style for bobby lock
because they wanted to make him
very much crossover that sort of every
kid in america could see themselves
in his role i meant nina how about you
but let's be honest
as much as we love bobby it's arnez from
one on one that we were crushing on
arnez turned out to be pretty much of a
heartthrob on the show i mean he played
guitar
he you know wore sleeveless shirts um he
had his muscles always out and
very much baby oiled he's very much a
lenny kravitz type character
a man can't watch a movie naked in his
own house
despite being a well-known actor robert
fell into it completely by surprise
i was actually avoiding a fight and i
tucked into a random building to avoid
the fight and that
building happened to be an acting school
so i was in there stalling and i was
just like
asking for a tour and asking like oh can
i fill out an application
and then 24 years later i'm not any
award-winning actor
the bad boy back in 1991 when hook was
released and dante bosco took to the
silver screen as rufio
he stole the hearts of more than just
the lost boys
rufio is a badass kid who's the leader
of lost boys
tough and a sword fighter and a little
crash bad boy turned good
by the end let's talk about the look so
the rufio look three mohawks the tryhawk
on top
red black shredded leather jacket
midriff shirt black and red
black skin tight holy jeans red tights
on any
red suede boots those hair pieces were
actually
dyed animal tail which
sounds crazy but that's what it was
dante couldn't have been more right for
the role
he got the part after a single audition
he didn't even have to read lines for
steven spielberg
he looked at me and he was like well you
know down to me
the audition thousands of kids across
the country it's like yeah and out of
all of them you're the only kid that
scared me
i got hooked after hook dante went on to
voice an anime character known for
having the most redeeming character arc
in
animation history prince zuko in avatar
the last airbender
i understand it's interesting to be a
teenage kid people have a crush on you
as a teenager
and then it's interesting to people to
have crush on you again and
specifically because of your voice i
don't know if i totally get it 100
but i think it's better that way
the player okay andrew keegan
where do we start when we think about
andrew keegan one
thing comes to mind
camp nowhere was my first studio film so
that would have been my first
kiss on camera trash
oh hi daddy and the girl her name was
marnette patterson
then there was seventh heaven jessica
how could i forget that one
we kissed a few times i also had a
kissing scene in the broken hearts club
which was with dean cain i remember a
lot of
nervousness why is it so scared to tell
everyone
did i mention that i kissed jessica
although in 10 things i hate about you
he got to date bianca stratford
well briefly i'm sure you know spray had
tomorrow
i think it's fair to say that i'm most
well known for the joey donner
role he was a bad guy he
had elements of ego and bravado
there was an endearingness to his
qualities
endearing maybe as opposed to a bitter
self-righteous hag
has no friends player or not
his picture was still on a lot of our
walls i've certainly
heard about the posters up on walls it
is
obviously somewhat you know
um an awkward conversation
when it comes up now that uh i used to
have your poster up on the wall
and it's happened but it's always a very
sweet encounter
well there you have it some of your boy
crushes and some of the stories behind
their iconic roles
who's gonna see that it's monday so it's
it's garbage day so this is like my
little secret to how i stay young